blinkist is the app that helps you
become a more well-rounded person by
letting you read or listen to an entire
non-fiction book in just 15 minutes you
can try it for free and get 25 off a
subscription by going to blinkist.com
pakman welcome to the david pakman show
i am jesse dolimore sitting in for david
while he is
luxuriating on vacation
um
today in america
especially related to kovid
there are two camps of people
you have the camp that is concerned for
their fellow citizens and want to stop
the onslaught of the virus that has
resulted in the deaths of over hundred
thousand americans and millions
worldwide
and the other camp is comprised of
people who are colluding against the
first camp
uh fortunately not unfortunately
fortunately we seem if you're watching
this and you're of like mind we're on
the first team
and fortunately now we have a government
that is standing in the gap for those
most in need relative to protection i
hold in my hand here
a memorandum for all department of
defense employees
written by lloyd austin former general
and now secretary of defense
and he is mandating
with the president's approval
seeking
president biden's approval to have all
military personnel and department of
defense employees vaccinated by
mid-september i'm going to read a little
bit from this memorandum because i
believe it's important to give context
of the words of the leaders
over the last week i have consulted
closely with the chairman of the joint
chiefs of staff the secretaries of the
military departments the service chiefs
and medical professionals
i appreciate greatly the advice and
counsel they provided
based on these consultations and on
additional discussions with leaders of
the white house coveted tax force i want
you to know that i will seek the
president's approval to make the
vaccines mandatory no later than
mid-september or immediately upon the
u.s food and drug administration
licensure whichever comes first
by way of expectation public reporting
suggests that the pfizer vaccine could
achieve full fda licensure early next
month
to defend this nation we need a healthy
and ready force
i strongly encourage all dod military
and civilian personnel as well as
contractor personnel to get vaccinated
now and for military service members to
not wait for the mandate
all fda authorized covid19 vaccines are
safe highly effective they will protect
you and your family they will protect
your unit your ship and your co-workers
and they will ensure we remain the most
lethal and ready force
in the world
now many of you probably have no idea
who i am
uh but for the edification of those who
don't know i served in the united states
marine corps for many years
and there is sure to be some backlash
among some of the more right-wing
uh nutters in the military and rest
assured there are many of them
when i was in the marine corps they they
did this uh dna testing where they took
a drop of blood and there was an outcry
from many
acting as though there was a conspiracy
afoot
and the same thing is going to happen
here
now what i find interesting
is the fact that
the
the same the same people in the camp who
talk about the military being too
sensitive and being too woke
are the same
that are going to act like this is
imposing some kind of a problem on the
military members
who are largely
dutiful people who care about their oath
to support and defend the constitution
who care about their country who care
about their neighbors
that's not the case with everybody
but it matters that our military
get vaccinated not just for the
communities in which they live
but so we have a viable
ready force
in case something does happen where they
need to be deployed
now
president biden released a statement
and in part he said i strongly support
secretary austin's message to the force
today on the department of defense's
plan to add the covet 19 vaccine to the
list of required vaccinations for our
service members not later than
mid-september secretary austin and i
share an unshakable commitment to making
sure our troops have every tool they
need to do their jobs as safely as
possible
these vaccines will save lives
that's what this is about
saving lives
this is about protecting
lives
and
in a not so abstract way
isn't that indeed what the military is
there for
to protect
lives
to care for the citizenry of this
country
to not be vaccinated goes against that
ethos
which brings us to the other side the
other camp
in republicans
who in an effort to own the libs
which seems to be their only function
they are pushing back against every
measure imaginable
to beat back the virus whether that be
mass mandates whether that be vaccines
whether that be social distancing
whether that be shutdowns uh
whatever effect they had on the economy
at every step
they push back
enter
josh fewerstein
another one of these evangelical nutter
butters who screams and yells and freaks
out
on stage to their audience
their congregation
listen
again get a little personal since most
people don't know who i am
i grew up a conservative
republican
i was indoctrinated in an evangelical
congregation for most of my
child for all of my childhood
i revered characters like
josh fewerstein
like greg locke
who david talked about
a few days ago
these are dangerous charlatans watch
this clip from josh fuerstein then we're
going to talk about it listen to me i
understand and let me speak now to the
cameras around the world to every pastor
that's watching this broadcast to every
christian that is coward in your home i
realize that for this last year that
maybe you've been fed fear and fear and
fear but the bible says that god has not
given us the spirit of fear but a power
and a love and a sound mind you have a
sound mind you don't have to wear the
mask you got jesus you don't need the
vaccine you've got jesus
[Music]
so i guess we're to believe that josh
fuerstein who much like me could could
use a few sit-ups in his life
that he's not vaccinated for anything
apparently he doesn't have the the
measles mumps rubella vaccine
he's probably not been vaccinated for
polio right
it's only this vaccine that's the
problem because it's the culture war du
jour
for conservatives
and grifters
just like him
who ostensibly
has a charge to protect his
flock he is doing a disservice not just
to the people in that audience who look
up to him and admire him he is doing a
disservice to the country at large
as he appears on ameri real america's
voice
like they're part of real america
and those of us who disagree
are not in real
america
this is all part and parcel pattern and
practice with uh what is taking place
right now in the headlines uh farron
talked about over the last couple days a
couple of guys
um
dick farrell the newsmax
and florida radio host
who who said not to get
vaccinated who called covet a hoax
who's now dead
from kovid
h scott apley
a republican
the leader in the republican party in
texas
uh advertised a mass burning party
and said boy i wish i could live where
you guys are i'd love to be a part of
that
he died on wednesday
in an effort to own the libs
to prove their points
they're acting
as they always do about most issues of
import and that is until it passes
beyond their nose
like a like a conservative who is all
against gay rights until they have a gay
kid
the same thing is happening because the
two gentlemen that i just talked about
that have been talked about more in
length by pharyn the last few days
their their families are admonishing
everyone please get the vaccine
covet is real covet is a killer
and the problem that we face right now
is not just from local city councilman
in texas or newsmax radio hosts
it's with
prominent governors in the republican
party like ron desantis right now
who just today announced he's
threatening to cut the pay suspend the
pay
of of school districts of teachers
educators
superintendents
if they enforce a mass mandate
protecting children this headline
from cbs4 miami
governor ron desantis office state
education board could withhold salaries
of superintendents school board members
who implement mass mandates here's the
the word from ron desantis
someone who is not protecting children
as we see kovid rates rise among
children
hospitalization rise among children ron
desantis is making it a policy objective
to not protect the least among us the
most vulnerable among us
his statement with respect to enforcing
any financial consequences for
non-compliance of state law regarding
these rules and ultimately the rights of
parents to make decisions about their
children's education and health care
decisions
it would be the goal of the state board
of education to narrowly tailor any
financial consequences to the offense
committed for example
the state board of education could move
to withhold the salary of this district
superintendent or school board members
as a narrowly tailored means to address
the decision makers who led to the
violation of the law
who led to the violation of the law but
also led to the protection of children
he continues education funding is
intended to benefit students first and
foremost
ron desantis said it with his own mouth
here
by his own pen or someone in his office
that education funding is intended to
benefit students first and foremost
and that doesn't just mean
benefiting them and their edu their
actual education but keeping them safe
in the place where they are
educated
just recently on meet the press with
chuck todd
the the president of the second
largest teachers union
decided they're going to reverse course
and they're going to support a covid
vaccine mandate because of that very
thing
protecting children
randy weingarten
the president of the american federation
of teachers on with meet the press watch
this um but i do think that the
circumstances have changed and that
vaccination is a community
responsibility and it weighs really
heavily on me that kids under 12 can't
get vaccinated and so that's so you know
that's i
very rarely
you know separate my personal views from
you know where i am as a leader of the
union but i have really watched
particularly in florida and missouri i
was in st louis yesterday i was in
florida on saturday and and you just see
this and and we have to counter
look you said it earlier we have to
counter the misinformation we have to do
we this is a public health crisis and
and the politics are infecting it but i
i felt the need as you know to bring
people together and to stand up and say
this as a matter of personal conscience
pointedly stated
circumstances have changed
and this is about it weighs
really heavily on me that kids under 12
can't get vaccinated
it should weigh heavily on every single
person in america educator or not pastor
or not politician or not
stupid commentator or not
people are dying our neighbors are dying
in our lifetime
unless you're a hundred years old
we've not seen something ripped through
our society like this
which team are you going to be on
the team that cares
or the team that colludes
against the team that cares
what if you could read 10 books in just
one sitting that's exactly what one of
my favorite apps lets you do it's called
blinkist and what they do is take
thousands of popular nonfiction books
they condense them down into text or
audio that you can consume in 15 minutes
blinkist makes sure that you're getting
all of the important core insights from
each book so it's perfect for exploring
a book you otherwise wouldn't have time
for if there's a full book you're
thinking about buying you can use
blinkist to get a sample first just
think how much you can enrich yourself
by being able to soak up an entire
nonfiction book in just 15 minutes i
recently read a brief history of time of
course by the great stephen hawking this
is a book that i have been aware of for
so long and other things got in the way
and it was fantastic to check it out on
blinkist blinkist has books on politics
philosophy science they have 27
different non-fiction categories and a
subscription is only about eight bucks a
month and you get the entire library but
you can try it totally free and get 25
off a subscription when you go to
blinkist.com
david pakman i've put the link right
underneath this video something i've
been talking about for certainly as long
as donald trump has been on the scene
actively involved in politics is the
rise of authoritarianism
the the risk of tyranny that we're
running
by allowing these people in power
along with authoritarianism is also
white supremacy and white nationalism
and just
outright racism
and chief the chief purveyor in the
united states right now of this kind of
rhetoric and what makes it most
dangerous is because he dresses up in a
suit and goes on fox news every single
night and has the most popular
uh cable news show in the history of
cable news
tucker carlson
well this last week tucker carlson has
been in hungary
giving victor orban who is a a wild
authoritarian in the mold of donald
trump
steve bannon has called victor orban
trump
before trump was trump something like
that
and i want to play a little audio or
video and audio of a speech that tucker
carlson is giving in hungary
knowing
that this speech is not for
people in budapest this this speech is
for people back home
this beach is for americans to hear and
he is signaling something
let's take a look
looking at these buildings which move me
not simply because they're old
and some have bullet holes
which in my view are a very useful
reminder
i wish i lived in a city full of bullet
holes in the building
we're going to stop it right there and
the reason we're going to stop it right
there because this is laughable
this is the same man
who whined and complained about having
to cower in his house while protesters
protested outside
and he is in fear
whining
yet i wish i lived in a town where there
were bullet holes and buildings
as he romanticizes this
disgusting because every morning you
look at them and you think to yourself
it could be really bad
because it's been really bad there's a
lot at stake make wise sober long-term
decisions or else you could wind up with
more bullet holes
it's true it's true it's true
it's true
tough guy strong man tucker carlson
never served one single minute
in the military in uniform
has never put his life in harm's way has
never put his life in danger
for any cause
and he stands there hugging himself
talking about how he wishes he lived in
the city with bullet holes in the
buildings
and if i would level
and i could spend all day
leveling very accurate accusations
against the american foreign policy
establishment but the main one would be
that they have no sense of how bad
things can get
and it's this is the bad side of the
upside of america america is an
optimistic country always has been came
from all around the world showed up in
this
mostly untouched continent with the most
fertile farmland in the world
and an ocean to separate us from the
lunatics
and it gave us the feeling that anything
is possible and everything has been
possible and i will never stop being
grateful for that or proud of it
but the downside to that the flip side
the obverse the other side of the coin
as you say in hungary
is that americans have no sense of how
bad things can get
that actually could be a lot worse
our physical isolation cuts us off from
the history of the rest of the world
there's not a passion to study what
happened before in a place that you're
building anew right right
yeah so we don't have a sense of that so
i love your bullet holes let me just say
i'm probably the only visitor to your
nation who's complimented your
small arms and artillery scars
but here's what i like more about the
landscape of hungary a few soviet
remnants notwithstanding it's pretty
it is pretty the buildings are pretty
the architecture uplifts
architectural uh
critic
tucker carlson so listen
what dr carlson i believe is doing here
is romanticizing
uh the bullets in the building
in the wake in the direct aftermath of
an attempted overthrow of the united
states government a violent insurrection
that took the lives
of americans
an attempted overturning of a free and
fair election tucker carlson sits here
on foreign soil
uh under the protection of an
authoritarian goon named victor orban
and says these things criticizes the
united states foreign policy
it has been practice for presidents
to to to tread lightly even even foreign
dignitaries you don't criticize your
country while
away
even when obama made what conservatives
call the apology tour he did not do that
they criticized anything that they could
perceive as a criticism of the united
states even when there wasn't one
and the script has flipped now we have
tucker carlson
doing that very thing
and being roundly applauded by it
by conservatives
and doing this
romanticizing signaling to the
insurrectionists while
denying that an insurrection took place
we all witnessed with our eyes what took
place what happened
with horror
if you are a reasonable person you
witnessed it
and now we're being told the sky is
green
not blue
that's not what happened
this is calculated
uh
on the other side of this
i want to read a little bit from this
daily beast op-ed
um
that is
in line with the behavior of tucker
carlson as the ring leader of the white
nationalist movement
in america
he's they've been talking about the
great replacement theory for months and
months and months
it's no longer a secret
it's no longer a dog whistle
they are fully embracing as a party
the great replacement theory and along
with it white genocide they call it
they whine about birth rates
they complain about immigration about
allowing refugees to come from a
desperate situation in their homelands
to the land of promise the land of
opportunity they complain about this
these are these are these are conspiracy
theories and complaints
that have been made for a long time
by individuals like the nazi face seen
punched around the world richard spencer
or david duke
or steve bannon
or stephen miller
the list is long paul gosar
steve scalise
who has said that he's just like david
duke without all the baggage
this is the modern republican party
donald trump
is the leader of this republican party
so i want to read from this article
because there are some great nuggets in
here that people in america need to wake
up to
what did orban do that makes him a model
worth emulating for conservatives in the
united states he transformed hungary's
once promising democracy into a
one-party state where he filled the
government and judiciary with political
apprehenics attacked the press and
political opponents abused his power to
enrich himself and his cronies promoted
anti-semitic conspiracy theories against
george soros and constructed a 109-mile
high-tech razor wire border fence
with serbia
sound familiar
if if i had if i had said what did
donald trump do that makes him worth a
model worth emulating and then finished
it off no one except for the part of the
the the border with serbia no one would
bat an eye
because the republican party is now
full-on authoritarian
they're not authoritarian light
they're anti-democratic
they're anti-american
continuing on orbon mobilized his base
into giving up their freedoms by
promising he will protect them and their
hungarian heritage from muslims refugees
and immigrants of color
and protect them from what he says are
political forces in europe who want a
replacement of population for
ideological or other reasons
instead he says
we hungarians have a different way of
thinking instead of just numbers we want
hungarian children migration for us
is surrender
and tucker carlson
takes to his fox news program and does a
week-long
commercial
for this individual
as though he is a beacon of what
leadership political and otherwise
should look like in the world
this is dangerous
it's dangerous because it is ushering in
a new wave
of thinkers
of intellectuals
who will look at this as the new way
forward
victor orban is not that new way forward
it is reactionary it is regressive
it is the opposite of the things that we
should strive for in america
progressive values
acceptance diversity caring for our
fellow citizens
whether they be citizens of the united
states or citizens of the world who are
reaching out in need
and tucker carlson turns his back
on that idea
disgusting
don't forget that the best way to
support the david pakman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the daily bonus show the regular show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire archive of every episode
dating back
a really long time and plenty of other
awesome membership perks go to
joinpackman.com
and use the coupon code better21 for a
huge discount join pacman.com
you know there are certain things that
are
guaranteed
one of those things is republican
hypocrisy
over the course of the last several
decades it has become crystal clear in
the minds of anybody who's paid
attention that republicans love to talk
a big game when democrats are in control
about budgets
they whine and cry from the rooftops how
are we going to pay for that
and it's not an altogether unreasonable
question
if asked in good faith
but during the the presidency of donald
trump an extra seven or so trillion
dollars was added to the national debt
while we were
in the midst of economic boom times
a trillion to a trillion and a half
dollar deficits
every year
even when things were great
when we should be squirreling away money
for a rainy day
preparing for a time when there would be
an economic downturn
we were we were
letting the rich off
uh the the fox into the hen house
the rich
all kinds of tax cuts
adding to the national debt
well now that democrats are in charge
there are several proposals that they're
trying to make that they're they're
forwarding
in hopes that christian cinema
and joe manchin won't get in the way
this new york times article
senate democrats begin 3.5 trillion
dollar push for big
bold social change
a senate budget blueprint which
democrats hope to pass this week would
ease passage of legislation that would
mark the biggest expansion of the social
safety net in nearly 60 years
and this is good news especially
in the state that we find ourselves in
covin
people on the brink of financial
collapse
millions and millions of americans
almost ready to be evicted from their
domiciles
because they cannot pay
their rent
people are in crisis
study after study after study over the
course of the last few years have
indicated that uh a large percentage of
americans could not withstand an
unexpected 400 charge
expense
things aren't great for millions of
americans and we need to update
how we take care
of those in need
reading from this article democrats
formally began their push on monday for
the most significant expansion of the
nation's social safety net since the
great society
of the 1960s
unveiling a budget blueprint that would
spend 3.5 trillion dollars on health
care
child and elder care education
and climate change
the budget resolution which the senate
democrats hope to pass by the end of
this week would allow the caucus to
piece together
social policy legislation this fall
paid for by raising taxes on the wealthy
large inheritances and corporations
should all 50 senators who caucus with
democrats hold together the measure
could pass the senate without a
republican vote
nullifying the filibuster threat
democrats plan to take up the measure as
soon as the senate approves a separate
one trillion dollar bipartisan
infrastructure bill which by the way
is a far cry
from the multi-trillion dollar
infrastructure proposal that biden
wanted
why
one
because of the recalcitrant
um
joe manchin the aforementioned joe
manchin
but also because republicans
they're not in the business of getting
things done they're in the business of
opposition
uh the one uh trillion dollar bipartisan
infrastructure bill which is scheduled
for a vote at 11 a.m tuesday
together the measures could secure
virtually all of president biden's 4
trillion
economic agenda rebuilding the nation's
roads bridges rail lines water systems
and electricity grid
while expanding public education social
welfare and health care
and remaking the federal tax code
that
is important
democrats are hard at work
bobbing and weaving and dodging the
arrows of republicans who aren't in the
business of progress
and democrats are trying to get
something done for the american people
to update
our country to refresh the way we do
things
because if this is the largest
uh the largest the biggest suspension of
a social security social safety net
nearly 60 years
what are we doing
if we're allowing republicans to
completely control the narrative like we
have for for a generation
on the minimum wage
what are we doing
if we we want to claim we live in
modernity we need to start acting like
it we need to start leading like it we
need to start legislating like it
if the congress can make all kinds of
exceptions because of covid to update
their voting proxy rules
we certainly can do that surrounding
this
and allowing republicans to get in the
way
especially where it relates to the
filibuster
isn't leadership
if you ask me it's cowardice
another item that democrats are trying
to get done here
falls on the shore the shoulders the
mighty shoulders
of elizabeth warren
another
new york times article
elizabeth warren will propose a minimum
tax on the nation's richest companies
now this comes on the heels
of reporting from from several years ago
where there were over 90 companies of
the largest corporations in america that
paid zero income tax
zero
john
deere zero
amazon
zero
this falls this comes on the heels of
the reporting from just a few months ago
from propublica
of all of the billionaires who didn't
pay any tax
elon musk
jeff bezos
warren buffett perennial liberal
advocate for for raising taxes on the
wealthy
he didn't pay
very much
reading from this article
senator elizabeth warren of
massachusetts and her allies will
propose a minimum tax on the profits of
the nation's richest companies
regardless of what they say they owe the
government
as part of the democrats 3.5 trillion
economic and social policy package
miss warren's so-called real corporate
profits tax was a key part of her
presidential campaign and she has
enlisted senator angus king the main
independent to help press her case that
profitable companies should be taxed
regardless of loopholes and maneuvers
that have allowed many of them to avoid
federal corporate income taxes
altogether
what does it say about our system the
morality of our system
that we demonize
those who are getting ready to be
evicted from their houses
we demonize
the unhoused
and we lift up as paragons as examples
of how to live
uh billionaires
who who enjoy
outrageous wealth
unimaginable wealth who pay nothing
into the system
instead they live off loans
using stock as collateral
and then that loan ends up being a
liability that they actually can get a
tax break from
it is immoral
i'm not necessarily opposed
to billionaires
i am opposed to a system that allows
them to to exist with impunity
continuing on here
the measure would require the most
profitable companies to pay a 7 tax on
the earnings they report to investors
known as their annual book value above
100 million
by taxing the earnings reported to
investors not to the internal revenue
service democrats would be hitting
earnings that companies like to maximize
not the earnings they try hard to
diminish for tax purposes
and this is what elizabeth warren had to
say about this
during the presidential campaign joe
biden and i disagreed on some tax
policies but there was one thing we
strongly agreed on
corporations shouldn't be able to tell
shareholders they were making huge
profits then tell the irs they made
nothing in profits
truer words
when jeff bezos and his cadre of
billionaire pals
benefit from a system that we have that
has made them what they are
of course there was hard work that went
into it i'm not saying that doesn't play
a role
but luck plays and plays an outsized
role
in the success of people like this it's
not just their ingenuity
there are a million
points of data
that lead
to their
success what's what's the phrase about
uh preparation and luck when when
combined
some nonsense saying
uh fortune favors the well-prepared or
whatever
all of that is true
but without luck
and without the sweat and the and the
the tears and the blood and the
sacrifice of people who work for these
corporations
they would have nothing
and to
to enjoy the spoils of everything that
is benefiting them that this country
offers and then to pay zero in tax
whether you be a corporation or whether
you be an individual like jeff bezos or
elon musk it is immoral it is
reprehensible and it needs to be
legislated
we need
people on capitol hill elected
representatives that is after all what
they do they represent us
and they need to do more for us
and not the people who who make
major payments to their pacs
major contributions to their political
campaigns
that is what's most important
we
the people
not we the corporation
if you value what we do at the david
pakman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com
davidpakmanshow where you can get access
to behind-the-scenes videos the daily
bonus show the commercial free daily
show as well as special discounts on
merch including hats hoodies
mugs and t-shirts you can support the
show for as little as two dollars a
month check it out at patreon.com
david pakman show the number of ways
that the republican party differs from
the democratic party
um
numerous
myriad ways
and i'm not just talking about policy
i'm not talking about uh economic
policies that are vastly different
relative to taxation
or just monetary policy in general
i'm not talking about social issues and
the respect and regard we have for our
fellow human beings
the the more humanist outlook i'm not
talking about that
right now i'm talking specifically about
the manner with which we hold our
leaders accountable
or
in in the in the way of the republicans
in the manner in which they do not
enter
andrew cuomo
last week leticia james
the new york state attorney general
concluded a lengthy investigation into
the behavior the conduct of governor
andrew cuomo
and they found that he has acted
inappropriately possibly criminally
related to female staffers
that went beyond
locker room talk like republicans like
to call it
he actually reached under women's
blouses
and assaulted them
now aides are running for the hills they
are quitting on mass
he is a man unto himself he is an island
unto himself
he's losing support of
long-time union leaders
black political leaders in new york are
abandoning him he's toxic
even his brother is under fire
melissa derosa this is from cnn
cuomo top aide melissa derosa resigns as
governor faces potential impeachment
new york governor andrew cuomo's top
aide melissa derosa resigned late sunday
less than a week after the release of a
report from the state attorney general
that found cuomo sexually harassed 11
women
it has been the greatest honor of my
life to serve the people of new york for
the past 10 years
new yorkers resilience strength and
optimism through the most difficult
times has inspired me every day
derosa secretary to the governor said in
a statement obtained by cnn
nancy pelosi has called for his uh um
resignation chuck schumer
fellow new yorker has also called
not just them though here's joe biden
when asked about it also
saying he should resign
back in march you said that if the
investigation confirmed the allegations
against governor cuomo then he should
resign so will you now call on him to
resign given the investigators said the
11 women were credible i stand by that
statement
are you now calling on him to resign
yes
and if he doesn't resign do you believe
he should be impeached and removed from
office
let's take one thing at a time here i
think he should resign i understand that
the
state legislature may decide to impeach
i don't know that for fact i've not read
all that data
and he's using a photo of you embracing
him in his self-defense to say that
these are commonplace kind of embraces
that he made in the allegations against
him do you condone that
look i'm not going to fly spec this
i am sure there are
some embraces that were totally innocent
but apparently the attorney general
decided there were things that weren't
so at this point
impeachment proceedings seem
unavoidable carl hesti
is the state the the speaker of the new
york state assembly
and they have initiated
an investigation impeachment inquiry
if i'm uh if i'm a baton man sometimes i
am
i would say that it is as i just
mentioned unav it's unavoidable it's
gonna happen and he will be removed
there's actually been uh sheriff's
offices uh contacted or at least one
where there very well could be criminal
charges brought against
um
current still governor
andrew cuomo
here's here's carl heasty
discussing the matter at a press
conference
task completed the assembly is working
to expeditiously
conclude our investigation
which covers a broad range of issues so
that we can bring this sad chapter of
our state's history to a conclusion
as i stated last week the governor has
clearly lost the confidence of the
majority members of the new york state
assembly
the attorney general's report lays out
in painful detail the many instances and
ways in which
he reportedly harassed and created a
hostile work environment for the
employees of the executive chamber and
others he came in contact with
i'm heartbroken
let me be clear no one should have to
endure the type of behavior detailed in
the attorney general's report
we had a historic moment in our state's
modern history for the first time in
more than 100 years the assembly is
undertaking
an impeachment investigation of a
sitting governor
chairman levine the members of judiciary
committee and my majority colleagues
understand the gravity
of the situation that we find ourselves
in today
future generations will look to us
and how we conducted ourselves in this
moment
in order to ensure due process which is
embedded in our system
we've asked for all evidence unredacted
and unfiltered used by the attorney
general's investigators to reach their
conclusions
the process to begin receiving that
information did not begin until saturday
evening we have not yet received all of
it we've seen a lot but not all of it
we've also asked the governor to submit
any relevant evidence he may have by
friday
august 13th
our goal is now to bring this matter to
a conclusion with all due haste no pun
intended
the judiciary committee has made
progress on the issues they have been
investigating
and to provide an update on those issues
our schedule and the progress of the
overall investigation i will now turn to
the chair of our judiciary committee
charles levine
now this is in stark contrast
to how republicans
fail
to hold their own accountable we
witnessed marjorie taylor greene
saying abhorrent
racist xenophobic things
and being able to keep her committees if
it were up to republicans it was
democrats who had to take it upon
themselves to vote her off
of her committees
she went on to to say nonsense and
and then apologize about comparing the
masks to the holocaust you may remember
and then gave a little press conference
i just learned about the holocaust
nonsense
matt gates he's in hot water for
unspeakable crimes
and still nothing he still sits on the
judiciary committee donald trump the
twice impeached
president
twice acquitted by republicans
clear crimes
clear outlining of obstruction of
justice in the mueller report
nothing
incited
an attempted overthrow
of the united states government and an
attempted overturning
of a free and fair election through
means not just
um violent insurrection but also using
the mechanism
the wheels and gears of government that
were at his disposal by using the doj
as a cudgel
to attempt
his
insurrection the
the just say it was fraudulent
and uh all take care of the rest
and how do republicans
hold themselves accountable
they don't
here's chuck grassley
the venerable octogenarian who works he
was he was the senator when i worked for
the senate many years ago
he's been there forever
this is him
waxing excuse making about why donald
trump had every right
to try to subvert the constitution and
attempt to overthrow the government
watch this
as he would call it cockamamie
reasoning
the president has every right to discuss
ideas
and strategies with his closest advisors
the president whether that president is
democrat or republican
should feel unrestrained
to bring ideas to his closest staff
for robust discussion
eventually the facts will come out
and trump will have to address them good
or bad
depending on the facts at hand
however
the essential question that should be
asked
what was the final decision
and that is my major concern about the
recent public comments
coming out of these interviews i've
discussed
relating to this new trump investigation
unlike my democratic colleagues
i won't discuss the evidence publicly at
this point in time
but let me remind the american public
with a couple
already public
points
did trump fire acting attorney general
jeffrey rosen
no he did not fire him
so donald trump according to chuck
grassley
has every right to counsel to gather his
his sage advisors
chuck grassley is acting as though
donald trump making excuses acting as
though donald trump was just he's just
floating ideas
as though he's talking about welfare
reform or tax reform or the the
never-ending infrastructure week
a president of the united states who has
raised his right hand and swore to
uphold the constitution to faithfully
execute his duties and support and
defend the constitution against all
enemies foreign and domestic
does not
get to foment
revolution
does not get to encourage and incite a
frothing
violent mob
to insurrection
to construct a gallow a hangman's gallow
on the on the on the lawn of the capitol
while chanting hang
mike
pence
no
senator grassley
that is not
how this works
to coin a commercial that's not how any
of this works
in lighter news
because it can't always be doom and
gloom
and anger and vitriol and resentment
toward the other side and their
anti-democracy
remember this tweet from elon musk
back in uh july 12 2021
those who attack space
maybe don't realize that
space
represents hope
for so many people
[Laughter]
listen say what you will about lily elon
musk
i have said a lot i am not his biggest
fan
uh i don't think he is an existential
threat though
um
this news is hilarious elon musk to
launch a satellite keep
how about this keep that in mind keep
that tweet in mind
as i read this story
uh that that people who attack space
maybe don't realize that space
represents hope for so many people
elon musk to launch a satellite that
will beam advertisements into space the
venture is a combined effort between
canadian technology startup geometric
energy corporation and spacex
[Laughter]
so space doesn't just represent hope it
also represents advertising
which is hilarious because this is about
as uh
low-tech as it gets it sounds a canadian
technology startup will be partnering
with elon musk's uh spacex
to make space advertisements a thing of
the future according to a report by
business insider samuel reed the ceo and
co-founder of geometric energy
corporation gec
told the outlet that the company is
working to create a satellite called
cubesat
real cool
one side of the cube sat will be used to
promote arts
excuse me ads art and logos
people and companies will be able to pay
to place their ads there by buying
pixels on the display screen with
cryptocurrency
the gec is planning on launching cubesat
into space via one of musk's musk muskas
spacex falcon 9 rockets which will
release it into orbit in space before
the rocket heads to the moon
big news
all right here's where it gets
just
[Music]
chefs kiss
hilarious
reed said
[Laughter]
come on man
reed said a selfie stick will be
attached to the cubesat
filming the display screen and allowing
people on earth to watch it
allowing people on earth to watch it on
a live stream through youtube
or twitch
so if you thought this was gonna be like
a massive uh
a massive screen like a billboard in
space that you could see from earth it's
not that it's a selfie stick with a
camera pointing back at it and you're
gonna have to go to youtube to actually
witness the ads
so yeah um
many people don't realize that space
represents hope
thanks for joining me you guys i'm jesse
dalmore sitting in for david pakman
see you next time
thanks a lot for watching today's show i
just want to take a second to tell you
about today's sponsors
blinkist is the app that helps you
become a more well-rounded person by
letting you read or listen to an entire
nonfiction book in just 15 minutes you
can try it for free and get 25 off a
subscription by going to blinkist.com
david pakman